>> Sean: GOD BLESS YOU, WE
WISH YOU ALL THE BEST.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK THERE ARE MORE OF THESE
CASES WE CAN FIND.
GIVE PEOPLE SECOND CHANCES.
JOINING US NOW, THE AUTHOR OF
THE RUSSIA HOAX, FOX NEWS LEGAL
ANALYST GREG      GREGG JARRETT.
HE IS WRITING A BOOK, AND THIS
WILL BE A BEST SELLER ALSO COME
UP THEY WILL BE FIGHTING AGAINST
EACH OTHER.
THE CASE AGAINST IMPEACHING
TRUMP, HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR
ALAN DERSHOWITZ.
I THINK THE BOOKS ARE
COMPLEMENTARY, AND I THINK WE
COULD DO IN OUR DEBATE, YOU GUYS
SIGNED BOOKS AND I COULD HAVE A
BEER.
>> HAPPY TO DO THAT.
>> LET'S DO IT.
>> Sean: FIRST I HAVE TO ASK
YOU ABOUT THIS WHOLE ISSUE WITH
ME.
PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ, YOU DID
KNOW THAT I WAS BEING SARCASTIC.
>> FIRST OF ALL YOU HAVE THE
PERFECT CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO
MAKE THE COMPARISON.
I AGREE WITH IT, THAT'S A
CONSTITUTIONALLY PROTECTED
ARGUMENT.
OBVIOUSLY, YOU DID IT WITH A
SENSE OF SARCASM SAYING, LOOK AT
WHAT SHE DID, BUT YOU WON'T GET
AWAY WITH IT IF YOU DON'T DO IT.
DO IT.
IT'S ABSURD.
>> Sean: I HAVE LAWYERS THAT
WILL TAKE ME ON AS A CLIENT
RIGHT HERE.
>> YOU WOULDN'T NEED US.
I COULD FIND YOU A FIRST-YEAR
STUDENT THAT WOULD WIN THAT
CASE.
>> Sean: HOW DO THESE PEOPLE
GET ON AIR?
THAT'S CRAZY.
>> I SUSPECT THE PEOPLE THAT
WERE CRITICIZING YOU NEVER
ACTUALLY LISTENED TO WHAT WAS
BEING SENT TO.
I PLAYED THE FIRST CLIP, SOMEONE
SAYING A CEASE AND DESIST ORDER
SHOULD BE ORDERED AGAINST YOU.
IF THAT GUY HAD A LAWYER, HE'S
AS DUMB AS A BUCKET OF HAIR.
OBVIOUSLY SATIRE AND PARODY AS A
PROTECTED SPEECH.
SARCASM DOES NOT CONSTITUTE
INCITING A CRIME.
MOST PEOPLE ARE YOU FOR THAT
HAVE NO IDEA WHAT THEY ARE
TALKING ABOUT LEGALLY.
WE WANT EVERYONE AT HOME, YOU
JUST SAW WHY THESE BOOKS WILL BE
BEST SELLERS.
ALL RIGHT, THE DOJ, THERE WAS A
SPY, PROBABLY TWO OR MORE.
YOU ARE A CONSTITUTIONAL
ATTORNEY, CONGRESS HAS A
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE IN
OVERSIGHT.
CHECKS AND BALANCES AND
SEPARATION OF POWERS.
WHY WON'T THEY TURN THE
DOCUMENTS OVER?
>> THEY SHOULD.
I'M A CIVIL LIBERTARIAN THAT
GOES BACK TO THE ANTIWAR
MOVEMENT WHEN INFORMANTS WERE
PUT IN THE ANTIWAR MOVEMENT.
THEY WERE PUT IN THE
ANTI-MARTIN LUTHER KING MOVEMENT
ANTI-MARTIN LUTHER KING MOVEMEN
MOVEMENT.
>> Sean: MARTIN LUTHER KING
WAS SPIED ON IN A HORRIFIC WAY.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SO AS A CIVIL LIBERTARIAN WHEN
YOU PUT SOMEONE IN A CAMPAIGN,
YOU'LL WANT TO SEE THE
JUSTIFICATION.
MAYBE THERE WAS JUSTIFICATION,
MAYBE IT WAS BUSINESS AS USUAL,
BUT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC HAS THE
RIGHT TO KNOW EVERYTHING ABOUT
THAT.
>> Sean: THIS IS A SCARY TIME.
LISTEN, I AM AS
PRO-LAW ENFORCEMENT AS ANYBODY.
I LOVE -- MY MOTHER WAS A PRISON
GUARD.
MY DAD WORKED IN PROBATION.
IT WAS A BIG DEAL, ALL OF MY
FAMILY, MANY OF THEM MORE POLICE
AND TWO MAY BE FBI AND THAT WAS
THE TOP OF THE HILL.
>> I NEVER PASS A POLICEMAN IN
THE STREET WITHOUT THANKING HIM.
I ALWAYS DO IT.
FIREMEN, POLICE, SCHOOL
TEACHERS.
PEOPLE WHO WORK HARD TO GIVE US
PROTECTION OR EDUCATION, I WANT
THEM TO KNOW I APPRECIATED EVERY
>> Sean: I DO THE SAME.
SO, THEY WON'T HAND IT OVER AND
THEN YOU HAVE ROSENSTEIN'S
COMPLEX.
I'M THINKING, THEY PROMISED TO
HAND IT OVER, WHY?
>> CONGRESS HAS EVERY LEGAL AND
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO SEE
THESE DOCUMENTS.
THOSE SEEKING IT ACTUALLY HAS
SECURITY CLEARANCE, THE GANG OF
EIGHT.
SO THERE IS NO LEGAL
JUSTIFICATION FOR HOLDING IT AND
YET THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE FBI HAVE A LONG AND
DISTINGUISHED RECORD OVER THE
LAST YEAR OF CONCEALING EVIDENCE
OF REDACTING RECORDS UNDER
NATIONAL SECURITY TERMS.
THEN WE FIND OUT WHEN THEY ARE
UNSEALED, THERE WAS NO SUCH
THING.
WHAT I WOULD RECOMMEND HOWEVER
IS FOR CONGRESS TO IMMEDIATELY
WRITE TO THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
AND SAY, DO NOT DESTROY A SINGLE
DRAFT.
WE WANT TO SEE WHAT THE ORIGINAL
LOOKED LIKE, WE WANT TO SEE
EVERY CHANGE, WE WANT TO KNOW
WHO CHANGED IT, WHY IT WAS
CHANGED AND WHEN IT WAS CHANGED.
>> AND THE INSPECTOR GENERAL
WOULD HAVE IT.
>> YOU CANNOT TRUST A BRIEFING
AS TREY GOWDY SAID.
THEY ARE JUST TELLING YOU WHAT
THEY CAN GET AWAY WITH AT THE
BARE MINIMUM.
YOU HAVE TO SEE THE DOCUMENTS
THEMSELVES.
>> Sean: I HAVE TO GO, BUT